This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. A few years ago, social scientist Francesca Gino was browsing the shelves at her local bookstore. She came across an unusual looking book in the cooking section. This recipe book, they look a little bit different and the title said, never trust a skinny Italian chef. And being Italian, it was very intrigued. And as I flipped through the pages, it became clear that this was not your typical recipe book. The dishes were playful, quirky, improbable.
这里是Hidden Brain，我是Shankar Vedantam。几年前，社会科学家Francesca Gino在当地书店浏览书架时，在烹饪区偶然发现了一本看起来很不寻常的书。这本食谱书看起来有点与众不同，书名是《永远不要相信一个瘦削的意大利厨师》。作为意大利人，她非常感兴趣。当我翻阅书页时，很明显这不是一本普通的食谱书。这些菜肴既俏皮、古怪，又令人难以置信。
Snails were paired with coffee sauce, veal tongue with charcoal powder. The recipes I titles like How to Burn or Sardine. And oops, I dropped the lemon tart. There were pictures of beautiful dishes who could resist the, at dish called the crunchy part of the lasagna. Now, if you know anything about Italians, first of all, we have lots of rules
蜗牛配咖啡酱，小牛肉舌配木炭粉。食谱的标题有《如何烧焦沙丁鱼》和《哎呀，我把柠檬挞掉地上了》。书里有精美菜肴的照片，谁能抵挡得住那道名为“千层面脆皮”的菜呢？现在，如果你对意大利人有所了解，首先，我们在烹饪方面有很多规矩。
when it comes to cooking. And second, we really cherish our traditional dishes, especially because they've been passed on for generations. But this chef, one of the most successful in the world, couldn't resist circling back to one big existential question. Why is it that we cook the dish in this way? Why is it that we cook the dish in this way? Why is it that we cook the dish in this way? It's the kind of question Francesca loved.
其次，我们非常珍视我们的传统菜肴，尤其是因为它们代代相传。但这位厨师，作为世界上最成功的厨师之一，无法抗拒地回到了一个重大的存在主义问题上。为什么我们要这样烹饪这道菜？为什么我们要这样烹饪这道菜？为什么我们要这样烹饪这道菜？这就是Francesca喜欢的那种问题。
As a professor at Harvard Business School, she has spent most of her career studying non-conformists, specifically people who break the rules and end up in trouble. But now, standing at the bookstore, she wondered when can defying norms lead to innovation? Can letting go of tradition lead to the most sublime examples of creative thinking? To find out, she got in touch with the man behind the cookbook, the so-called Jimmy Hendrix of Italian cooking, Massimo Batura.
作为哈佛商学院的教授，她职业生涯的大部分时间都在研究不墨守成规的人，特别是那些打破规则最终惹上麻烦的人。但现在，站在书店里，她想知道什么时候违背规范能带来创新？放弃传统能带来最具创造性思维的崇高范例吗？为了找出答案，她联系了这本食谱背后的男人，那位被称为意大利烹饪界的吉米·亨德里克斯（Jimmy Hendrix）——马西莫·博图拉（Massimo Bottura）。
After a few conversations, you said, look, if you really want to understand the business, you've got to come to Malena. And I was like, of course, why say no to any invitation to a three-mesh-long star restaurant? I'm on my way. This week, we'll follow Francesca on her mission to understand the minds of successful non-conformists. Her book about this quest is called Rebel Talent, why it pays to break the rules at work and in life. It continues our annual summer series, Think Deeply, you 2.0.
经过几次交谈，他说，听着，如果你真的想了解这家店，你必须来摩德纳。我当时想，当然，谁会拒绝去一家米其林三星餐厅的邀请呢？我已经在路上了。本周，我们将跟随Francesca去了解成功的不墨守成规者的思想。她关于这次探索的书名为《叛逆天赋：为什么在工作和生活中打破规则是有回报的》。这是我们年度夏季系列节目“深度思考，你2.0”的延续。
Authenticity is contagious. I have been dragged into this all the way kicking and screaming. Ideas and advice about how you can respond to life's chaos. Just check to my inbox, just check to my phone real quick. With wisdom. I think we really need to shift our thinking. Rebels are not troublemakers, they're not outcast. Rebels are people who break rules that should be broken. They break rules that hold them and others back and their way of rule breaking is constructive rather than destructive. It creates positive change. So I showed up at the restaurant for my first day with my notebook and basically it was given an apron.
真实性是会传染的。我一直被拖进这一切，又踢又叫。关于如何应对生活混乱的想法和建议。检查一下我的收件箱，快速检查一下我的手机。带着智慧。我认为我们真的需要转变思维方式。叛逆者不是捣乱者，他们不是被排斥的人。叛逆者是打破那些应该被打破的规则的人。他们打破那些阻碍自己和他人的规则，他们的打破规则方式是建设性的，而不是破坏性的。它创造了积极的改变。所以我带着笔记本出现在餐厅的第一天，基本上被发了一件围裙。
For the entire day I was put to work in the front of the house as a server. And again, it was an amazing experience because I had no qualification. I clearly didn't know what I was doing. I made a lot of mistakes, but that was just an example of doing things a little bit differently. So of course if you're a smart chef, the one thing you don't do is bring an amateur into your three Michelin star restaurant and ask her to start serving the dishes, I can just imagine all the ways that that could go wrong. Did it? That is exactly what was going through my head as I was making mistakes.
整整一天，我都被安排在前厅做服务员。这又是一次了不起的经历，因为我没有任何资格。我显然不知道自己在做什么。我犯了很多错误，但这只是做事方式略有不同的一例。当然，如果你是一位聪明的厨师，你绝对不会做的一件事就是带一个业余爱好者进入你的米其林三星餐厅，并让她开始上菜，我简直可以想象出所有可能出错的方式。真的出错了吗？这正是我在犯错时脑子里想的事情。
So from putting the very carefully arranged dishes down onto the table, that are very specific ways in which the dish gets arranged so that you get the right anticipation of what the dish is going to be about as you edit. And throughout the day, the team members were working with me in the front of the house were just helping me. And when I was making mistakes, they were very subtly trying to correct us. So they were adjusting the plate. Or if I brought to a table the wrong
从把精心摆放的菜肴放到桌子上，到摆放菜肴的特定方式，这样你就能在编辑时对这道菜的内容有正确的预期。整整一天，在前厅和我一起工作的团队成员都在帮助我。当我犯错时，他们会非常微妙地试图纠正我们。所以他们会调整盘子。或者如果我给一张桌子拿错了
utensils that they would show up, somehow bring another set that was the right set for the type with dish that was being served So I understand that if I were to visit the restaurant I might sometimes see Massimo Batura Outside unloading produce from the trucks or sweeping the pavement. He doesn't seem like someone who stands on airs He's very much into the trenches One of the first thing that he does when he shows up at the restaurant in the morning is to put his white chef's coat on, and then he does go outside with a broom and sweep the streets.
餐具，他们就会出现，不知怎么地拿来另一套，那是适合所上菜肴的正确餐具。所以我明白，如果我去参观这家餐厅，我有时可能会看到马西莫·博图拉在外面从卡车上卸下农产品或清扫人行道。他看起来不像是一个摆架子的人。他非常深入一线。他早上到餐厅做的第一件事就是穿上白色的厨师服，然后拿着扫帚去外面清扫街道。
And you're there looking at him, and the sous chef, and the people working in the restaurants are there looking at him, and you ask the question, why is it that he's doing that? But the second question that you ask yourself is, why is it that he's doing that? But the second question that you ask yourself is, why is it that I'm not doing it? And so you're feeling motivated to take on roles and activities that are roles that are not scripted
你站在那里看着他，副主厨和在餐厅工作的人也在看着他，你会问这个问题，他为什么要那样做？但你问自己的第二个问题是，他为什么要那样做？但你问自己的第二个问题是，为什么我不那样做？所以你感到有动力去承担那些不是根据你在餐厅的位置或工作地点而设定的角色和活动。这非常令人耳目一新。当然，他实际上也试图将这种方法带到他制作的食物中。我想让你听听这段音乐，因为你说这位厨师实际上要求他的员工根据这首歌制作一道菜。那么Francesca，到底发生了什么？你怎么能根据一首歌制作一道菜呢？这是马西莫·博图拉激励厨房工作人员的众多方式之一，他真的要求他们发挥自己的贡献和声音。
because of where you sit or where you work in the restaurant. It's very refreshing. And of course, he actually tries to bring this approach to the food that he's making as well. I want you to listen to this clip of music because you say the chef actually asked his staff to build a dish based on this song. So what was going on Francesca? How do you make a dish based on a song? It was one of the many ways that Massimo Batura inspires the people working in the kitchen and really asked them to bring out their own contribution and their own voices.
所以你会看到他走进外面，或者提到一首歌的名字，或者一首不同的诗，或者他最近读到的某个短语的名字，或者他在艺术展上看到的一件艺术品的名字，他试图做的是要求人们思考那首歌或那件艺术品是如何激励他们想出自己的菜肴的。他核心想要做的是确保人们不会只是出现在工作中。他们不会以某种方式把自己的身份留在门外，而是展现真实的自我。他们提出自己的想法，提出自己的贡献，而不受他们的背景、国籍或受过多少培训的影响。
So you would see him walk into the outside or a different name of a song or a different poem or a the name of a phrase of something that he was reading recently or the name of a piece of art that he saw at an art show and what he's trying to do is ask him people to think about how that song or how that piece of art inspired them to come up with their own dish. And what is trying to do at the very core is making sure that people don't show up at work. And somehow they leave their identity at the door, but rather they show up and they are being who they are. They're bringing their ideas forward, their contributions forward, independent of their background, their nationalities, or how much training they have.
当你和餐厅的员工交谈时，他们说厨师在激励他们方面扮演了什么角色？他们是否真的同意这些技巧确实激发了他们最好的一面？员工们所说的是，非常有趣的是，马西莫是一位从不说“我、我、我”的领导者，他总是谈论“我们”。他把餐厅描述为一个团队或一艘船，事实上，他经常谈论在一艘海盗船上
And when you spoke to the staff at the restaurant, what did they say the role of the chef was in inspiring them? Did they actually agree that these techniques were actually bringing out the best in them? What the staff has said, which is really interesting, is that Massimo is the type of leader who never says, hi, hi, hi, hi, he's always about the we. He describes the restaurant as a crew or as a ship, as a, in fact, he often talks about being on a pirate ship
有时外面的水域会很动荡，但正是因为我们将贡献出个人的力量，同时意识到我们是一个团队，无论大海多么动荡，我们都会成功。人们确实被他领导餐厅的方式所激励。还有一件事让马西莫成为叛逆者。他问了很多关于为什么事情是现在这个样子的问题。对于Francesca来说，无畏的好奇心是叛逆天赋的核心。
and sometimes the waters out there are going to be turbulent, but for the very fact that we are going to bring out our individual contributions, but we're going to do so being aware that we are part of a team, no matter how turbulent the sea is, we're going to succeed. And people do feel very inspired by the way he leads the restaurant. Here's another thing that makes Massimo a rebel. He asks a lot of questions about why things are the way they are. For Francesca, a fearless curiosity is at the heart of rebel talent.
博图拉通过问“为什么不呢？”这个问题开了一家餐厅。他没有任何经营餐厅的经验，更不用说烹饪了，因为他没有上过烹饪学校。他在法学院。他在那里待了两年，只是为了坚持他父亲想要的。然后他并不喜欢它。然后他的一位兄弟告诉他这家待售的餐厅。
Butura opened up a restaurant by asking the question, why not? Yet no experience in running a restaurant, let alone cooking because he didn't go to culinary school. He was in law school. He was there for two years as a way to stick to what his father wanted. And then he didn't enjoy it. And one is brother, one of these brothers told him about this restaurant that was up for sale.
他真的问了自己这个问题，“为什么不呢？”这就是好奇心。我们经常专注于效率和完成工作。我们有一个很长的待办事项清单。但这样做往往是以牺牲我们像小时候那样探索的能力为代价的，而那种探索对我们来说是非常自然的。所以我看到太多的领导者过于关注效率，以至于人们的好奇心被关闭了，这太糟糕了，因为好奇心会带来各种伟大的结果和成果。
He really asked himself the question, why not? That's curiosity. We are so often focused on efficiency and getting things done. We have a very long to do list. But what that often comes at the cost of is allowing us to explore the way we used to when we were a very little kid and that came very naturally to us. So I see too many leaders who focus so much on efficiency that curiosity shut down in people and that's too bad because curiosity leads to all sorts of great results and great outcomes.
整本书中贯穿着一种张力，这种张力是专业知识与实验之间的张力。我想反复谈论这一点，但我也想通过你探索的另一个故事的视角来谈论它。你研究了切斯利·萨伦伯格机长（Captain Chesley Sullenberger）的故事，也就是大家熟知的萨利机长（Captain Sully）。他当时在全美航空1549号航班的驾驶舱内。飞机刚从纽约拉瓜迪亚机场起飞。一群鸟飞进了飞机。我想播放一段驾驶舱记录仪的录音。萨利机长使用呼号“仙人掌1539”与纽约的空中交通管制员通话。飞机正在以惊人的速度下降。
There's a tension that runs through much of the book and the tension is the tension between expertise and experimentation. And I want to come back and talk about this over and over again, but I also want to do it through the lens of another story that you explore. You've looked at the story of Captain Chesley-Sullenberger, better known as Captain Sully. He was at the controls of US Airways Flight 1549. The plane had just taken off from La Guardia Airport in New York. A flock of birds flies into the plane. I want to play you a bit of tape from the cockpit recorder. Captain Sully radio's air traffic controllers in New York using the call sign, Cactus 1539. The plane is descending at a terrifying rate.
管制员试图弄清楚该怎么做。塔台说有紧急情况要返航。是1549。如果他撞鸟了，他失去了所有引擎。他失去了引擎的推力，无法立即转弯。事实上，1549，哪个引擎？他说他两个引擎都失去了推力。明白了。萨利机长询问降落选项，但他很快决定没有一个能行得通。事实上，1549，右转航向80。
The controllers try to figure out what to do. The tower's top-eater park has got a emergency returning. It's 15.90. If he birch strike, he lost all engine. He lost the thrust in the engine to the turning immediately. The fact is, 15.29, which engines? He lost thrust in both engines, he said. Got it. Captain Sally asks for landing options, but he quickly decides none of them will work. The fact is, 15.29, turn right to 8.0.
你可以立即降落。我想看到跑道。我们做不到。然后呢？我们要把飞机降落在哈德逊河上。Francesca，你将这次事件描述为叛逆天赋的一个显著例子。为什么？如果你考虑萨利机长所处的环境，我们大多数人会选择显而易见的答案。我们压力很大，没有时间，我们真的很紧张。我们的思维会很自然地变得狭隘。但如果你阅读事故报告，或者如果你和
You can land right away. I want to see the bomb. We can't do it. And then? We're going to plane in the Hudson River. Francesca, you describe this incident as a striking example of rebel talent. Why? If you think about the situation that Captain Sally was under, most of us would go to the obvious answer. We are under a lot of pressure, we have no time, we are really stressed. And what our mind would do very naturally is to narrow our way of thinking. But if you read the accident reports or if you were to talk to
萨利交谈，你就会明白他所做的是考虑各种选择。他不断问自己我能做什么。在一个大多数人会封闭思想的地方，他保持了开放的心态。他没有选择降落在最近的机场这个显而易见的答案，而是对这个问题进行了创造性的思考，并想出了降落在哈德逊河上的主意。这就是叛逆者的全部意义所在。那些不只是遵循剧本或遵循他们在培训中学到的东西的人，他们保持开放的心态。他们从非常不同的角度看待问题，无论他们有多少时间去思考，然后他们
Sally, you don't understand that what he did instead was to consider options. He kept asking himself what it is that I could be doing. And in a place where most people would close their mind, he kept his mind open. Rather than going to the obvious answer of lending to the nearest airport, he thought creative about the problem and came up with this idea of lending in the Atson River. So that's what rebels are all about. People who rather than just following the script or just following what they've learned in their training, they stay open-minded. They look at the problem from very different perspective, no matter how much time they have to think about it and then they
创造性地解决了问题。萨利机长有208秒的时间。从他发现引擎失去推力到他将飞机迫降在哈德逊河上，那是真实的，叛逆的天赋。这个故事再次向我揭示的一件事是专业知识与实验之间的这种张力。所以，如果你有专业知识，但你不愿意尝试，你就会变得可预测，变得无聊。
creatively solve the problem. Captain Sally had 208 seconds. By the time he discovered that he had no thrust in the engine and the time he ditched the plane in the Atson River, that's true, rebel talent. One of the things again, the story reveals to me is this tension between expertise and experimentation. So if you have expertise, but you're not willing to experiment, you become predictable, you become boring.
但如果你在没有专业知识的情况下进行实验，那可能会显得业余。如果你让我把飞机降落在哈德逊河上，那将以灾难告终。所以，当你将专业知识与实验结合起来时，会发生一些事情。那就是魔法所在。完全正确。关于萨利机长，许多人可能不知道的一件事，是我在有机会采访他时学到的，那就是事故发生时。他有驾驶各种飞机的经验。他还曾作为志愿者参与调查过往事故的团队，试图了解发生了什么。所以他在那种可怕的情况下拥有如此丰富的经验。然而，关于他的一件事是，每次他走上飞机，
But if you experiment without having expertise, that can be amateurish. If you ask me to land a plane in the Hudson River, it's going to end in disaster. So, there's something that happens when you combine expertise with experimentation. That's where the magic is. Exactly. One of the things that many people might not know about Captain Sally, that I learned when I had the opportunity to interview him, is that by the time the accident happened. He had the experience flying all sorts of planes. He also served as a volunteer in teams that look at prior accidents and try to understand what it is that it happened. So he had so much experience once he was in that dire situation. And yet, one of the things that is true about him is that every time he walked on a plane,
他都会问自己一个问题，我能学到什么。我该如何学习。这怎么可能不同？他拥有那种让他保持开放心态的智力谦逊，尽管他在整个职业生涯中积累了大量的经验。这就是我们经常错过的。
he asked himself the question, what it is that I could learn. How is it that I could learn. How is it that this could be different? He had that type of intellectual humility that kept him open-minded, despite the fact that he was accumulating throughout his career a lot of experience. That's what often we miss out on.
我们获得了经验，通过获得经验和知识，我们相信我们都拥有正确的答案，我们没有保持谦逊，我们没有那种让我们专注于还有什么要学而不是我们已经知道什么的智力谦逊。萨利机长和马西莫·博图拉尝试了大胆的事情并取得了非凡的成果。钦佩他们很容易，但为什么像他们一样那么难呢？事实证明，一种好奇的心理障碍经常阻碍我们。我们正在谈论成功的叛逆者，那些挑战现状并产生创造性突破的人。
We gain experience and by gaining experience and knowledge, we believe that we all have the right answer and we don't stay humble, we don't have that type of intellectual humility that keep us focused on what's left to learn rather than what it is that we know already. Captain Sally and Massimo Batura tried daring things and achieved extraordinary results. It's easy to admire them, but why is it so hard to be like them? It turns out a curious psychological roadblock often gets in the way. We're talking about successful rebels, people who defy the status quo and produce creative breakthroughs.
我们已经看到了这在萨利机长和博图拉厨师身上是如何运作的。那么为什么这样的人如此罕见呢？为什么我们许多人觉得很难引导我们内心的博图拉？你可能认为问题在于，我们不是专家，我们不是熟练的厨师或伟大的飞行员。但事实上，问题往往恰恰相反。我们知道得太多了。我和我的同事们对经验可能是有代价的这个想法很着迷，因为在我们的许多课程中，我们实际上是在告诉学生他们应该获得
We've seen how this worked with Captain Sally and Chef Batura. So why are people like this so rare? Why do so many of us find it hard to channel our inner Batura? You might think the problem is, we're not experts, we're not skills chefs or great pilots. But in fact, the problem is often the opposite. We know too much. My colleagues and I were fascinated by this idea that experience could be costly, because in a lot of our classes we're actually there telling our students that they should gain
知识，信息就是力量，经验很重要。因此，我们在一个包含数百万个数据点的数据集中探索了这一点，这些数据点关于心脏病专家在进行心脏直视手术时的行为。有趣的是，我们可以探索这些心脏病专家发生了什么以及他们的行为。在食品药品监督管理局发布公告后，如果我简化一下，基本上告诉他们，他们在手术中使用技术的方式对患者不利。我们在数据中发现令人震惊的是，外科医生的经验越丰富，他们改变行为的可能性就越小。
knowledge, the information is power, that experience is important. And so we explored this in a data set of millions of data points on how cardiologists behave in their surgery when they do open our surgeries. And what was interesting is that we could explore what happened to this cardiologist and their behavior. After the Food and Drug Administration put out an announcement that if I were to simplify, basically told them that the way they were using the technology in their surgery was not good for patients. And what we found in the data that was striking is that the more experienced the surgeon had, the less likely they were to change their behavior.
这意味着正如你所建议的那样，当我们获得经验时，我们经常觉得自己是专家，即使当我们听到信息或看到证据表明我们错了时，我们也认为自己更了解。因此，在我们获得经验的同时保持那种学习心态是非常非常重要的。当然，这很难做到，恰恰是因为一旦你知道了什么，你就会问自己，为什么我要回到成为初学者的状态？你描述了哥伦比亚大学进行的一项非常有趣的研究
That means that as you were suggesting, when we gain experience often, we feel like the expert and we think that we know better even when we hear information or when we see evidence that speaks to the fact that we are wrong. And so having that learning mindset as we're gaining experience is so, so important. And of course, that's difficult to do precisely because once you know something, you ask yourself, Having that learning mindset as we're getting experience is so, so important. And of course, that's difficult to do precisely because once you know something, you ask yourself, why should I go back to becoming a beginner, you describe a very interesting study that was done out of Columbia University
观察吉他手，以及专家吉他手可以重新像初学者一样思考的一种方式。告诉我那个研究。这是Ting Zhang的一项研究。她对这个想法很着迷，即一旦你成为专家，就很难用新手的眼光看待问题。所以她认为她可以解决这个问题的其中一种方法是要求专家重温成为
looking at guitar players and one way that expert guitarists could learn to once again think like beginners. Tell me about that study. This is a study by Ting Zhang. And she was fascinated by this idea that once you're an expert, it's very difficult to look at problems with the eyes of a novice. And so one way she thought she could address this very issue is by asking expert to relive the experience of being
新手的经历。所以在她的一项研究中，她招募了有经验的吉他手。她要求其中一些人（对照组）像平时一样演奏。当然，他们听起来很棒。她要求其他人用非惯用手演奏一首歌。左撇子用右手演奏，右撇子用左手演奏。这立刻让他们感觉自己又成了初学者。这种经历非常令人谦卑，因为你被提醒了你开始时
an novice. So in one of our studies, she recruited experienced people who played guitar. She asked some of them, the control group, to play as they would on a typical day. Of course, they sounded great. She asked the others to play a song with their non-dominant hand. Lefty's played with the right hand, right-handed people played with their left hand. It instantly made them feel like beginners again. The experience is very humbling because you are sort of reminded of what it is that you
知道和不知道的东西。当她比较这些人给其他有兴趣学习弹吉他的人的建议时，当涉及到这第二组人时，建议比那些像往常一样弹吉他的那组人更有帮助。当我听到你告诉我关于吉他研究的事情时，它让我想起了你在书中提到的另一件事。这种洞察力是，在许多领域，创新者往往不是那些在这些领域待了很长时间的人。
knew and didn't know as you started. And when she compared the advice that these people were giving to others who were interested in learning how to play the guitar, the advice was much more helpful when he came to this second group of people rather than the group of people who played the guitar as you would usually do. As I'm hearing you tell me about the guitar study, it reminds me of something else you have in the book. This insight that in many fields, the people who are the innovators are often not the people who've been in those fields for extended periods of time.
往往是该领域的新手，他们掌握了足够的规则，但没有在文化中花费太多时间以至于变得僵化。这些人实际上能够接受这种文化并将其推向新的方向。你谈到了这在科学中是如何运作的。有些人试图解决
That it's often the newcomers to a field who have just about enough information to have mastered the rules, but I have not spent so much time in the culture that they've become hide bound. These are the people who are actually able to take the culture and move it in new directions. You talk about the role of how this works in science. There have been people who've tried to solve
科学问题，通过邀请不一定是科学专家的人，但试图解决科学问题的人，通过邀请不一定是科学专家的人，而是局外人。想到这样一个事实，即我们所有人可能在生命中的某个时刻都有过这样的时刻，当时我们试图解决一个问题，我们觉得我们是专家，但我们被卡住了，无法想出解决方案，这非常有趣。有趣的是，当我们实际上引入可能没有正确专业知识的人时，他们会从非常不同的角度看待问题。那种在观点、看法、看待和分析问题方式上的差异，
scientific problems by inviting people who are not necessarily science experts, but people who've tried to solve scientific problems by inviting people who are not necessarily science experts but people who are outsiders. It's quite interesting to think about the fact that probably all of us have had at some point in our lives or another, a moment in which we were trying to tackle a problem where we felt we were the expert, but we were stuck and we were not able to come up with a solution. And what is interesting is that when we, in fact, bring in people who might not have the right expertise, they're going to look at the problem from a very different perspective. And that type of difference in perspective, in opinions, in the way you're looking and analyzing the
在帮助你找到解决方案方面可能非常强大。确实有公司利用了这种洞察力并创建了像礼来公司（Eli Lilly）这样的企业，当遇到非常困难的挑战时，他们会把这些挑战发布出来，这样不仅拥有正确专业知识的人可能想解决这个问题，而且其他人，那些可能没有正确专业知识的人，也可以参与进来，而且解决方案往往正是来自这些人。这是一个很好的提醒，专业知识虽然很棒，但如果我们用它作为一种说“我知道答案，我是专家”的方式，就会产生潜在的问题，你从狭隘的角度看待问题，通常只从一个角度，那就是我们自己的角度。相反，拥有这种学习心态，将新手引入问题，使我们现在能够从许多不同的角度和观点看待情况。
problem, can be quite powerful in helping you find a solution. And there are companies out there that in fact have used this insight and created businesses like ilay lily would be one of them where when there are very difficult challenges, they put them out there such that not only the people with the right expertise might want to tackle the problem, but all others, people who might not have the right expertise, can chime in, and often the solutions come exactly from those people. It's a good reminder that expertise, while wonderful, creates potential problems if we use it as a way of saying, I know the answer, I'm the expert, you look at the problem tune errorally, usually only from one perspective, and it's our own perspective. And instead, having this learning mindset bringing in novices into the problem allows us to now look
当然，这谈到了多样性价值的想法。我认为这是我从你刚才所说的话中得到的见解之一。在房间里混合那些从不同角度看待事物的人可能本身就很有价值。拥有从非常不同的角度看待问题的人，实际上是解决棘手问题的关键。但现实是，我们许多人不想受到挑战。无论是在工作还是在家里，过日子要容易得多。
at the situation from many different angles and viewpoints. Of course, the speaks to the idea of the value of diversity. I think that's one of the insights that I'm getting from what you just said. Having a mix of people in the room who look at things from different perspectives could just be inherently valuable. Having people who look at the problem from very different perspective is, in fact, a key to solving tough problems. But the reality is that many of us don't want to be challenged. It's so much easier to go through life, whether I work or at home for that matter.
和那些只是点头说“是的，我同意你”的人在一起。但叛逆的领导者和叛逆的员工是那些真正试图让自己周围的人思考方式不同，并且确实挑战他们的人。我问Francesca关于她在书中提到的另一个叛逆者。你可能熟悉她在电影中的作品，比如《塞尔玛》（Selma），这是对1965年马丁·路德·金领导的一系列著名民权游行的描述。这意味着抗议，这意味着游行，这意味着扰乱和平，这意味着入狱，这意味着
With people that just nod their heads and say, yep, I agree with you. But rebel leaders and rebel employees are people who really try to surround themselves with people who think differently and with people who do challenge them. I asked Francesca about another rebel she mentions in her book. You might be familiar with her work in movies such as Selma, an account of a series of famous civil rights marches led by Martin Luther King Jr. in 1965. That means protest, that means march, that means disturb the peace, that means jail, that
风险，这很难。你说她的故事揭示了关于叛逆天赋的另一个非常重要的想法，那就是对刻板印象保持警惕的重要性，认识到刻板印象实际上可以作为一种防止我们创造性思考的紧身衣。在生活的各个领域，我们都受到刻板印象的影响。或者更广泛地说，我们接受了别人传给我们的社会角色。艾娃·杜威内（Ava DuVernay）的故事是一个美丽的故事，因为她根本没有那样做。这来自一个决定在职业生涯后期从事电影制作的人。
means risk, and that is hard. And you say that her story reveals another really important idea when it comes to rebel talent, which is the importance of being vigilant to stereotypes, to recognize that stereotypes can actually serve as a kind of straight jacket that prevents us from thinking creatively. In all sorts of spheres of life, we are affected by stereotypes. Or more generally, we accept social roles that others have passed on to us. And the story of Eva Duverne is a beautiful one because she just doesn't do that. And this comes from a person who decided to go to filmmaking later in her career.
她当时在做一份不同的工作，她说，我要转换并进入这份工作。在从别人那里得到的建议中，每个人都在谈论真正得到别人支持、接触网络的重要性。她没有这些。她只是开始拿起摄像机，制作自己的电影。事实上，她创作的第一部电影是由她自己的积蓄支持的。
She was doing a different job and she said, I'm going to switch and enter this job. And in the advice that she was receiving from others, everybody was talking about the importance of really being supported by others reaching out to networks. She didn't have that. And she just started picking up the camera and working on our own movies. And in fact, the first films she created were supported by her own savings.
然后她因自己的工作而闻名，因为她不接受商业规则，但在某种意义上，她在工作并与它们对抗。作为一个故事，这非常令人惊叹和鼓舞。所以对我来说，我在38岁时制作了我的第一部电影，我的第一部剧情片。所以永远不会太晚。我只是从外面开始的。我们已经看到了叛逆者是如何建设性地打破规则的。即使在没有权力掮客支持的情况下，他们也会继续前进。一旦他们取得成功，他们就会继续像初学者一样思考
And then she became known for the work that she was doing, for the fact that she was not accepting the rules of the business, but in a sense she was working and finding against them. And it's quite amazing and inspiring as a story. And so for me, I made my first film, my first speech of film when I was 38. So it's never too late. I just started from the outside. We've seen how rebels constructively break the rules. They push ahead even when they don't have the support of power brokers. And once they achieve success, they continue to think like beginners
并竭尽全力向那些不同意他们的人学习。那么你如何激活你内心的不墨守成规者呢？请继续关注。今天我们谈论的是叛逆者，那些打破社会规范并实现令人难以置信的想象力壮举的人。为什么这是我们极少数人会做的事情？一个问题是我们知道得太多了。我们成为各自领域的专家，然后退回到熟悉的常规中。
and go out of their way to learn from those who disagree with them. So how can you activate your inner non-conformist? Stay with us. Today we're talking about rebels, people who break free of social norms and achieve incredible feats of imagination. Why is there something so few of us do? One problem is that we know too much. We become experts in our fields and then fall back on familiar routines.
我们忘记了如何用新鲜的眼光看待世界。但这不必如此。Francesca Gino说，成为叛逆者是一种我们所有人都可以培养的技能。有时只需要小步骤。几年前，她想知道让人们对不舒服感到自在是否是激活他们内心叛逆者的第一步。她要求学生站在朋友和同学面前唱歌，Journey乐队的《Don't Stop Believin'》。你能为我设置这个实验吗，Francesca？当我运行这项研究时，我把手放在头发上，我想起了这一点。
We forget how to see the world with fresh eyes. But it doesn't have to be this way. Francesca Gino says that being a rebel is a skill that all of us can cultivate. Sometimes it takes only small steps. A few years ago she wondered if getting people to feel comfortable about being uncomfortable could be the first step in activating their inner rebel. She asked students to stand before their friends and classmates and sing, don't stop believing by journey. Can you set up the experiment for me, Francesca? I'm putting my hand in my hair as I was reminded when I was running this study.
这是一项受到以下观念启发的实验：当我们打破规则，当我们脱离别人对我们的期望时，我们会感到一种自信。为了测试这一点，我把本科生带到实验室，我要求他们参与你刚才听到的任务。站在麦克风前的视频前，在其他参与者看着你的情况下，唱《Don't Stop Believin'》。那是其中一首歌。
This was a study that was inspired by the notion that when we break rules, when we break away from what others people expect of us, we feel a sense of confidence. And so to test that, I brought undergraduates to the lab, and I asked them to engage in the task that you just heard. Stand up in front of a video with a microphone, and in front of other participants watching you, singing, don't stop believing. That was one of the songs.
一些参与者确实那样做了，但另一些人被要求在唱歌时戴上头巾，他们告诉我这让他们感到不舒服，然后我有兴趣看看他们在任务期间经历的焦虑和压力以及自信程度，除了他们的表现之外，在这两种不同的条件下是否会有所不同。他既观察了压力的生理测量，也观察了他们在回答关于他们感到多自信的问题时的自我报告测量。人们在同龄人面前唱歌时戴着头巾
And some of the participants did just that but some others were asked to wear a bandana as they were singing something that they told me made them uncomfortable and then I was interested in seeing whether the anxiety and stress that they experienced during the task and the level of confident in addition to their performance Was going to be different in these two different conditions and he was Both looking at physiological measure of stress, but also their self-reported Measures in answering the question of how confident they felt people were wearing the bandana while they were singing in front of their peers
感到更自信，压力更小。所以尽管他们认为自己会感到更不舒服，而且这对他们来说会更难。事实上，他们戴着头巾，这是同龄人没想到的事情，实际上对他们有帮助。这不仅仅是他们的感受和生理机能。当你从他们保持音准的程度来看表现时，因为卡拉OK客观地记录了这一点，他们做得更好。所以这里有一个悖论，因为在一个案例中，你要求一组学生唱
felt more confident, felt less stress. So despite the fact that they thought they would feel more uncomfortable and that it would be harder for them, the fact that they were they would feel more uncomfortable and that it would be harder for them. The fact that they were wearing their bandana, something that the peers didn't expect was actually helpful to them. And this is not just their feelings and their physiology. When you look at the performance in terms of how much they stay on tune since the karaoke was recording that objectively, they did better. So there's a paradox here because in the one case, you're asking one set of students to sing
这首歌，这显然很困难，特别是在教室里的朋友面前，这很难做到。但第二组被要求做一些更困难的事情。你要求他们唱这首歌，还要戴上这种不墨守成规的头饰，你会认为第二组会做得更差，但你发现恰恰相反。完全正确。我们经常认为打破规则会导致更糟糕的结果，并且会让我们感到不舒服，在某种程度上确实如此，但它随后会转化为自信。而那种自信转化为更好的表现。这很矛盾，但这是成为叛逆者的重要教训之一。
the song, which is clearly difficult, and especially before your friends in a classroom, it's difficult to do. But the second group is being asked to do something even more difficult. You're asking them to sing the song and also where this non-conforming you know, headdress and you would think that the second group would do worse but you found exactly the opposite. Exactly. Oftentimes we think that breaking rules is gonna lead to worse outcomes and it's gonna make us feel uncomfortable and it does to a certain extent but it then turns into confidence. And that confidence translates in better performance. It is paradoxical but it's one of the big lessons in being rebelliousness.
它确实有回报。我明白你也发现了关于你自己的这一点。你进行过某种实验，尝试不同类型的鞋子对你的观众产生的影响。有一次，我被要求连续教授两节课，同一节课。每节课我有110名高管。由于我在两节课中教授相同的内容，我想我可以做的是在两节课之间换鞋。这正是我所做的。
It does pay off. I understand that you've discovered this about yourself as well. You've run experiments of a sort where you try on the effects of different kinds of footwear and the effects it has on your audiences. One time I was asked to teach two classes, the same class back to back. And in each class I had 110 executives. And since I was teaching the same content across the two classes, what I thought I could do is change my shoes in between the two classes. And that's exactly what I did.
所以，想象一下这位教授穿着一套非常漂亮的西装。第一节课，我穿着正式的皮鞋。这可能是学生们对哈佛商学院教授或一般在行政教育中教学的教授的期望。但第二节课，我把皮鞋换成了一双红色的运动鞋。走去教室很有趣。我的同事们用奇怪的眼神看着我，心想，
So, picture this professor dress up in a really nice suit. And for the first class, I was wearing formal leather shoes. Probably what the students expected from an HBS professor or a professor in general of teaching in exec head. But for the second class, I changed out my leather shoes for a pair of red sneakers. And it was interesting to walk to class. My colleagues were giving me the strange look, thinking,
她在做什么。我要去教我的第二节课。在每节课结束时，我给高管们做了一个小调查。在调查中，我问他们诸如“你认为我的咨询费是多少？”、“你认为我作为教授在哈佛商学院有多大的影响力？”、“你认为我多久在像《哈佛商业评论》这样的从业者导向杂志上发表文章？”之类的问题。有趣的是，这些是用来衡量学生认为我有多大影响力的指标。而且
what it is that she's doing. And I was going to teach my second class. And at the end of each of the two classes, I gave the executives a little survey. And in the survey, each of the two classes, I gave the executives a little survey. And in the survey, I was asking them questions like, how much do you think I charge for my consulting? How much influence do you think I have at HBS as a professor? How often do you think I publish in a practitioner-oriented magazine like Harvard Business Review? And what was interesting is that these are measured to capture how much influence the student thought I had. And
调查结果显示，他们有更高的尊重。他们认为我是一个更有影响力的人。当我教他们同样的内容时，只是穿着红色的运动鞋。所以当然，听这个的人明天会出去买红色运动鞋并戴上头巾，因为这就是你所说的会让他们被更认真对待的原因。我最近为一家公司做了一次关于叛逆天赋问题的培训，邀请我去的那些人都在团队中穿着红色运动鞋，他们整天都得到了很多赞美和问题。所以是的，这可能是从这项研究中学到的教训之一。
what the survey results showed is that they had a higher respect. They thought of me as a more influential person. When I taught them the same content, just wearing red sneakers. So of course, people listening to this are going to go out and get red sneakers and wear bandanas tomorrow because that's what you're saying is going to get them taken more seriously. I recently did a training for a company around the issues of Rebel Talent and the people who invited me out were all in a team wearing red sneakers and they got a lot of compliments and questions throughout the day. So yeah, so that could be one of the lessons learned out of this research.
我们所有人都能更好地打破规则的另一种方法是保持对周围发生的事情的关注。有时我们太专注于手头的工作，以至于我们没有看到这种情况如何为我们提供展示领导力和真实性的机会。莫里斯·奇克斯（Maurice Cheeks）在2003年4月25日的NBA季后赛中就有过这样的机会。莫里斯陷入了波特兰开拓者队，他的球队在系列赛中以0-2落后。这是一个高风险的时刻。现在为了纪念美国并向为我们国家服务的男男女女致敬，我们的国歌。
Another way we can all get better at breaking the rules is to stay mindful of the things happening around us. Sometimes we're so focused on the job at hand that we fail to see how the situation might afford us opportunities to demonstrate leadership and authenticity. Maurice Cheeks had such an opportunity on April 25, 2003 during the NBA playoffs. Maurice was caught up in the Portland Trailblazers and his team was down 2-0 in the series. It was a high stakes moment. And now to honor America and salute the men and women serving our country with our national
两万名兴奋的篮球迷在波特兰的玫瑰花园。当一个看起来很紧张的13岁女孩走向麦克风时，人群安静了下来。请欢迎，由你们，粉丝们投票选出的，我们的丰田“感受明星的感觉”促销活动的获胜者，娜塔莉·吉尔伯特（Natalie Gilbert）。哦，你看得见吗？起初事情进展顺利。
anthem. Twenty thousand excited basketball fans are in the Rose Garden in Portland. The crowd falls silent as a nervous looking 13-year-old girl walks toward the microphone. Please welcome, as voted by you, the fans, our winner of the Toyota Get the Feeling of a Star promotion, Natalie Gilbert. Oh, say can you see? At first things go well.
娜塔莉看起来很自信、放松。我们如此自豪地欢呼，星星是？正如你所听到的，她犯了一个错误。她在寻找她的父亲以获得一些支持，然后有人出现帮助她。是莫里斯·奇克斯。在这样一个时刻，你可能认为他所有的注意力都会集中在他的球队和他们在比赛中的机会上，莫里斯有心智去意识到一个孩子遇到了麻烦。
Natalie looks confident, relaxed. What so proudly we hailed at the stars are? And as you can hear, she is making a mistake. She's looking for her father to get some support and then somebody shows up to help her. It's Maurice Cheeks. At a moment when you might think that all his attention would be focused on his team and their chances in the game, Maurice has the presence of mind to realize that a child is in trouble.
他有一个和娜塔莉差不多大的女儿。他冲过去站在她身边。他搂住她，说，来吧，来吧。来吧，来吧。星条旗，让我们。星条旗。最后的梦想。最后的梦想。
He has a daughter about Natalie's age. He rushes up to stand beside her. He drapes an arm around her and says, come on, come on. Come on, come on. Star-lice, let's. Star-lice. Last dream. Last dream.
娜塔莉犹豫了。她不认识这个穿着灰色西装站在她身边的陌生人。但莫里斯·奇克斯现在正在唱歌，娜塔莉被带动了。娜塔莉看起来又自信了，她的声音高亢起来。然后体育场里发生了一些事情，成千上万的粉丝，球员们，他们看到了莫里斯所做的事情。现在每个人都在唱歌。
Natalie hesitates. She doesn't know this stranger in the gray suit who has come up to stand by her side. But Maurice Cheeks is now singing, and Natalie is lifted along. Natalie looks confident again, her voice soars. And then something happens in the stadium, thousands of fans, the players, they see what Maurice has done. And now everyone is singing.
这是胜利的。我经常在课堂上使用这个视频片段。片段之后我问的问题是，这家伙声音好听吗？他并不好听。有趣的是，他没花时间就走进去帮忙。他在2万名粉丝和数百万家庭观众面前让自己变得脆弱。
It is triumphant. I often use the video clip in class. And then the question that I ask after the clip is, does this guy have a good voice? And he doesn't. And what is interesting is that he took him no time to walk in and help. He made himself vulnerable in front of 20,000 fans and millions of viewers from home.
这就是叛逆者所做的。他们不担心别人在想什么，但他们以一种赢得周围人尊重的方式让自己变得脆弱。真实性是有感染力的。真实性是会传染的。一旦我们看到人们让自己变得脆弱，而不是消极地评判他们，
That's what rebels do. They are not worried about what others are thinking, but they make themselves vulnerable in a way that gained them respect from those around them. There's something infectious about authenticity. There is authenticity is contagious. Once we see people making themselves vulnerable, rather than judging them negatively,
这就是叛逆者所为。他们不在乎别人的想法，但他们以一种让自己变得脆弱的方式，赢得了周围人的尊重。真实具有某种感染力。真实是会传染的。一旦我们看到人们展现出脆弱的一面，而不是消极地评判他们，
we actually respect them, and we ask ourselves questions about why is it that we're covering up? We should be more willing to be authentic as well and bring ourselves forwards as we interact with others. One of the things that makes this book so interesting for Ancheiska is that you've spent so much of your career exploring the pitfalls of breaking the rules. And of course, this is a standard fare for many academics.
我们实际上尊重他们，并会问自己为什么要掩盖真相？我们也应该更愿意表现得真实，在与他人互动时展现真实的自我。对于安切斯卡（Ancheiska）来说，这本书之所以如此有趣，原因之一是你职业生涯中花费了大量时间去探索打破规则的陷阱。当然，这对许多学者来说是家常便饭。
We've had co-authors of yours like Docker Calcinar and Dan Arieli on the show talking about unethical behavior, the risks of power. Powerful people often feel they can break the rules, act with impunity. In some ways it makes sense that many of us are nervous about rule breaking because we've seen the consequences of rule breakers and lots of times breaking the rules doesn't lead to good consequences. Fundamentally breaking rules and being rebellious means leaving what's comfortable and known and familiar. And so people perceive it as risky business, but what the book hopefully teaches us,
我们曾邀请过你的合著者，如多克·卡尔西纳（Docker Calcinar）和丹·艾瑞里（Dan Arieli）来节目中讨论不道德行为以及权力的风险。有权势的人往往觉得他们可以打破规则，肆无忌惮。在某种程度上，我们许多人对打破规则感到紧张是有道理的，因为我们见过违规者的后果，而且很多时候打破规则并不会带来好的结果。从根本上说，打破规则和叛逆意味着离开舒适、已知和熟悉的环境。因此，人们认为这是一种冒险的行为，但这本书希望能教会我们的是，
or at least in looking at the story of these rebels, what I've learned is that it might feel uncomfortable at first, but really it does pay off. We are more confident when we're breaking rules. We also are much more engaged in the activities that we are working on, and we also end up with better, more trusting relationships. So there is a lot of goodness that comes from rule breaking, but we do need to shift our thinking. It's rule breaking that is constructive, not rule breaking that is destructive. So when I think about a lot of the years that I spent looking at cheating and why is
或者至少在审视这些叛逆者的故事时，我学到的是，虽然起初可能会感到不舒服，但它确实会有回报。当我们打破规则时，我们会更自信。我们也会更投入到正在进行的工作中，最终还会建立起更好、更信任的关系。因此，打破规则会带来很多好处，但我们需要转变思维。是建设性的打破规则，而不是破坏性的打破规则。所以，当我想到我多年来研究欺骗行为以及为什么
it that people steal and what organizations could do about it, that's rule breaking that is destructive. But the type of rule breaking that we're talking about now, though risky or uncomfortable, it's rule breaking the leads to positive change. I'm wondering if the distinction is as simple as that though, isn't it possible that in some ways people who break the rules can in fact go over the edge? I remember visiting Facebook many years ago and there were posters on the walls saying you know move fast and break things.
人们会偷窃，以及组织能对此做些什么时，那是破坏性的打破规则。但我们现在谈论的这种打破规则，尽管有风险或令人不适，却是能带来积极变革的打破规则。不过，我很好奇这种区别是否真的那么简单？难道在某些方面，打破规则的人实际上可能会越界吗？我记得多年前参观Facebook时，墙上贴着海报，上面写着“快速行动，打破陈规”。
And Facebook of course was an enormous rebel success story in Silicon Valley. But increasingly a lot of people feel the company has gone too far, that it's broken too many rules, that it's actually run a foul of what we think a company should be doing, even on questions of national security and democracy. And I understand the point you're making, it would be nice if we could easily demarcate the rule breakers who are constructive, from the rule breakers who are destructive, but isn't it possible that there is actually a pretty thin line between the two? When I think about the various businesses and organizations that I studied
当然，Facebook是硅谷一个巨大的叛逆成功故事。但越来越多的人觉得该公司走得太远了，打破了太多的规则，实际上违背了我们认为一家公司应该做的事情，甚至在国家安全和民主问题上也是如此。我理解你的观点，如果能轻易区分建设性的违规者和破坏性的违规者固然很好，但两者之间难道不存在一条相当细微的界限吗？当我想到我研究过的各种企业和组织时，
as I was working on the book, I've noticed a couple of things that seems to be really important when we think about this thin line. First is the fact that in businesses where people are encouraged to break the rules, the leaders are very clear on the rules that should not be broken, context in which you absolutely need to follow the guidelines or the rules. So one example that comes to mind is aerial investment as Chicago based money management firm, if you were to visit the firm, what you would see is that the leaders are really trying to make sure that people are staying open-minded, that they're using all the talents that I talk about in the book. But if you go to certain places,
在撰写这本书的过程中，我注意到了一些在思考这条细微界限时似乎非常重要的事情。首先，在鼓励人们打破规则的企业中，领导者非常清楚哪些规则是不应该被打破的，即在哪些情况下你绝对需要遵循准则或规则。我能想到的一个例子是位于芝加哥的资产管理公司Aerial Investment。如果你去参观这家公司，你会看到领导者确实在努力确保员工保持开放的心态，并运用我在书中谈到的所有才能。但如果你去某些地方，
everybody in the firm is going to tell you there, you got to follow the rules. So for example, if a letter goes out to a client, everybody knows that the three different people need to look at the letter to make sure that it's clear, that there are no typos, that is the language is appropriate because otherwise you would affect the repetition of the firm negatively. That's a rule that everybody knows should not be broken. So as these examples suggest that there is much clarity around the rules that really you don't want people to break. And second, and other things that I noticed in businesses that encourage rebelliousness is the fact that once you trust people to break rules, they seem to have very
公司里的每个人都会告诉你，你必须遵守规则。例如，如果有一封信要发给客户，每个人都知道需要有三个人审阅这封信，以确保内容清晰、没有错别字，并且用词得当，否则会对公司的声誉产生负面影响。这是一个每个人都知道不应打破的规则。因此，正如这些例子所暗示的那样，对于那些你确实不想让人打破的规则，有着非常明确的界定。其次，我在鼓励叛逆精神的企业中注意到的另一件事是，一旦你信任人们去打破规则，他们似乎就拥有非常
good judgment. They sort of decide on their feet the situations where you really should be putting your head down and follow the script rather than using your mind in a creative way to come up with a different solution. So that type of good judgment is something that I've seen in so many different rebels and in so many organizations where people are encouraged to be rebellious. You sometimes describe this as positive deviants in the book, but of course, in many companies and organizations, someone who comes along and says, let's do things differently, the way we've been doing things all
良好的判断力。他们会当机立断，决定在哪些情况下你应该埋头苦干、遵循剧本，而不是用创造性的思维去寻找不同的解决方案。这种良好的判断力是我在许多叛逆者和许多鼓励人们叛逆的组织中看到的。你在书中有时将其描述为“积极的越轨者”，但当然，在许多公司和组织中，如果有人站出来说，让我们换种方式吧，我们一直以来做事情的方式
this time has been wrong. I mean, that person is often seen as a troublemaker. Often times what's different between a troublemaker and a rabble in the way I think of rabbles is the delivery. Many people after I was working on the book and they heard about it, asked me to go and watch them in their work because they said I'm clearly a rebel but it's not paying off for me. And so in a couple of cases I did go and I was watching them as they were interacting with their colleagues. And the elements of rebelliousness were there,
都是错的。我的意思是，那个人通常会被视为麻烦制造者。通常，麻烦制造者和叛逆者之间的区别，在于我所认为的叛逆者的表达方式。在我写书之后，很多人听说了这件事，要求我去观察他们的工作，因为他们说：“我显然是个叛逆者，但这对我来说并没有什么回报。”因此，在几个案例中，我确实去了，并观察了他们与同事的互动。叛逆的元素确实存在，
but the delivery was wrong. So they were coming across as arrogant. If they were in a discussion and they thought that the discussion needed to go in a different direction, rather than saying, I see the value in your idea. And I think we can also bring to bear a different perspective. They were more shutting down the idea, letting the person know how wrong the idea was prior to bringing in forward their ideas. They were the troublemakers, maybe people are breaking rules, just for the sake of breaking rules, rebels instead, are really being constructive in their approach in a way that creates
但表达方式错了。他们表现得傲慢自大。如果他们在讨论中认为讨论需要朝不同的方向发展，他们不是说：“我看到了你想法中的价值，我想我们也可以引入一个不同的视角。”而是直接否定了这个想法，让对方在提出自己的想法之前就知道他们的想法有多么错误。他们是麻烦制造者，也许人们只是为了打破规则而打破规则；而叛逆者则不同，他们以一种真正具有建设性的方式行事，从而创造出
positive change. I'm wondering how writing and researching this book has changed your own life. How have you tried to internalize these lessons at home as a parent, as a partner, as a friend, as a colleague, and as a professional? In all spheres of life, I've changed my behavior quite a bit, or at least I find myself pausing and trying to learn how to be an effective rebel. There is a story that I tell in the book about my son, who at the time was about four and a half year old. This is the time where curiosity is as it best. You keep asking why and what if type of questions. And it's early in the morning. And Alex is my son name, is having his breakfast.
积极的变革。我很好奇撰写和研究这本书是如何改变你自己的生活的。作为父母、伴侣、朋友、同事和专业人士，你是如何尝试在家里内化这些经验的？在生活的各个领域，我的行为都有了很大的改变，或者至少我发现自己会停下来，努力学习如何成为一名有效的叛逆者。我在书中讲了一个关于我儿子的故事，当时他大约四岁半。这是好奇心最旺盛的时期。你会不断地问“为什么”和“如果……会怎样”之类的问题。那是清晨，亚历克斯（Alex，我儿子的名字）正在吃早餐。
So a bowl of milk with some cereal. And as is sitting at the counter, steering is milk. It looks on my husband and says, Daddy, do we still have the coloring bottles that we use to use when we color exit Easter? So my husband is sort of looking confused, but he says, yes, and he walks to the cabinet, he opens it up and gets the bottle to Alex and said, Alex, what are you going to do with it? And Alex smiled and said, I'm going to color my breakfast. And you should have seen the face of my husband, he was confused, sort of disappointed, and it looked back at Alex and said,
一碗牛奶加麦片。他坐在柜台边，搅拌着牛奶。他看着我丈夫说：“爸爸，我们还有复活节涂色彩蛋时用的那种食用色素瓶吗？”我丈夫显得很困惑，但他还是说：“有。”他走到柜子前，打开它，把瓶子拿给亚历克斯，说：“亚历克斯，你要用它做什么？”亚历克斯笑了笑说：“我要给我的早餐上色。”你应该看看我丈夫的表情，他很困惑，甚至有点失望，他看着亚历克斯说：
Alex, we don't do that. And Alex, being a four and a half year old boy, said, why not? Very reasonable question. And then my husband even more confused with Alex's answer, looked at me and said, we don't do that, right? And that was a beautiful moment for me. As we were trying to struggle through this question of whether we do it or we don't do it, Alex opened up the bottle and started to put red coloring in his milk and all of a sudden, the cereals were happily swimming in pink milk. And it's a perfect example of how often we go through life. And there are rules that we put out there that maybe should be questions. Why is it that milk needs to be white for breakfast? I actually tried it.
“亚历克斯，我们不那样做。”亚历克斯作为一个四岁半的男孩，问：“为什么不呢？”这是一个非常合理的问题。然后我丈夫对亚历克斯的回答更加困惑，他看着我说：“我们不那样做，对吧？”那对我来说是一个美好的时刻。当我们努力纠结于我们是否应该这样做时，亚历克斯打开了瓶子，开始往牛奶里滴红色色素，突然间，麦片就在粉红色的牛奶里欢快地游动起来。这是一个完美的例子，说明我们经常是如何度过一生的。我们设定了一些规则，也许这些规则应该受到质疑。为什么早餐的牛奶必须是白色的？我实际上尝试了一下。
So I now had pink milk, yellow milk, green milk, and it tastes just the same to me. If anything, you're really smiling as you start off your day. Francesca, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Bright. Really fun to be talking to you, so thank you. Francesca Gino is a professor at Harvard Business School and the author of Rebel Talent, why it pays to break the rules at work and in life. This week's show was produced by Laura Correll and edited by Tara Boyle.
所以我现在喝过粉红色的牛奶、黄色的牛奶、绿色的牛奶，对我来说味道是一样的。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是你在开始新的一天时真的会微笑。弗朗西斯卡（Francesca），非常感谢你今天参加《Hidden Brain》节目。和你聊天真的很开心，谢谢你。弗朗西斯卡·吉诺（Francesca Gino）是哈佛商学院的教授，也是《叛逆的才能：为什么在工作和生活中打破规则是有回报的》（Rebel Talent）一书的作者。本周的节目由劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。
Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Path Shah and Thomas Liu. Our unsung hero this week is Bryn Winterbottom. Bryn works on NPR's Rad team, which is both an acronym and a great description for NPR's research, archives, and data strategy team. Bryn helps us with research questions, both large and small, and she also makes sure that resources like show transcripts are available on our website. Thank you, Brain. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter.
我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）、帕斯·沙阿（Path Shah）和托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）。我们本周的无名英雄是布林·温特博顿（Bryn Winterbottom）。布林在NPR的Rad团队工作，这个名字既是一个缩写，也是对NPR研究、档案和数据战略团队的绝佳描述。布林帮助我们处理大大小小的研究问题，她还确保像节目文字稿这样的资源可以在我们的网站上找到。谢谢你，布林。想了解更多《Hidden Brain》的内容，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。
If you like this episode, please be sure to share it with a friend. We're always looking for new listeners to Hidden Brain. Do you have a project you've been meaning to finish, but are struggling to make progress on? Next week, our YouTube.io episode is filled with strategies for how you can work more deeply. I plan out the day like a chess player moving the pieces around. This is when I'm going to work on win. I don't let my mood dictate how my day unfolds. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR.
如果你喜欢这一集，请务必与朋友分享。我们一直在寻找《Hidden Brain》的新听众。你是否有一个一直想完成但进展缓慢的项目？下周，我们的YouTube.io节目将充满关于如何更深入工作的策略。我像下棋一样规划我的一天，移动棋子。这是我打算工作的时间。我不会让我的情绪左右我一天的进展。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），这是NPR。
how my day unfolds. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我一天的进展。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击文字稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。